Samsic à une de mes chouchous c'est
celle qui vient sur mes genoux tous les
soirs me raconter une histoire
l'histoire du soir un lien d'amour entre
Jacky et ses abeilles pour cette
apiculteur
passion est une mission au quotidien le
16 juin dernier il s'est associé au parc
France Miniature à Élancourt pour
installer une ruche pédagogique près de
50 000 insectes fourmis au milieu des
monuments grâce à des ouvertures sur la
structure le public peut admirer le
travail complexe de la colonie où il y a
très bien des abeilles qui ont construit
les alvéoles et qui sont en train de
stocker du bien à l'intérieur
l'objectif c'est de visualiser donc des
abeilles qui sont en pleine activité qui
sont plein labeurs qui participent à
notre bien-être qui vont participer à la
pollinisation des des fleurs bien
entendu ramener du nectar ramener du
pollen ramener de la propolis Jacky
boisseau a réalisé lui-même la
conception de cette maison pédagogique
pour éviter les piqûres un système de
cheminée culminant à 2 mètres 50 du sol
permet aux abeilles d'entrée et de
sortir librement lorsqu'on utilise une
ruche
classique elles sortent à 50 cm donc
aura de l'herbe et elles vont décoller
et elles vont décoller elles vont avoir
un petit peu de temps pour monter en
altitude mais elles vont décoller plus
difficilement et donc moins de sécurité
pour les visiteurs du parc l'enjeu à
France Miniature en installant cette rue
cheminée au cœur du parc c'était de
montrer à nos visiteurs que ces petites
abeilles sont pas du tout offensives
quand on les dérange pas et puis surtout
c'était l'occasion pour nous de porter
un message et de sensibiliser à la
préservation de l'environnement des
panneaux éducatifs seront placés dans
les allées durant l'été afin de mieux
comprendre ces espèces pour prolonger
l'expérience des ateliers autour du miel
et des abeilles seront organisés avec
Jacky boisseau durant les journées du
patrimoine les 16 et 17 septembre
prochain
[Musique]